tatum oladipo strips him again victor
oladipo ahead to strews strews drive
blocked by brown
jaylen brown with a rejection meanwhile
down the other end of the floor
jalen brown
defense there on the block comes down to
the other end
klay thompson wiggins
looney
three steph got it oh what a shot
he is ruthless
and and much needed as well in this
series
19 for thompson
nine at the half ah luca
jackhammers
great attack no one comes to help
finishes with the dunk
brunson defense snaps it outside to
wiggins goes by bullets drops the
successful challenge by steve kerr and
the warriors it's not a offensive foul
on andrew wiggins nor is it a defensive
foul on luka doncic but it is a good
bucket and poster by andrew wiggins
challenge successful and wiggins has his
third career playoff double sometimes
it's enough with the talking
you got to get out there and perform
[Applause]
lee smith blocks it off the backboard
wiggins there on a quick show by curve
now the blitz
he snaps it in the corner kenny smith
three he's got two
number one how about this assist by luka
doncic
finds finny smith in the corner and he
knocks it down
downshifts 106. pull with a blitz and a
1-3 luca
[Applause]
look at steph he's holding that right
thigh he sure is
see this is the problem
[Music]
butler's got robert williams on him
tries the three-pointer comes up short
butler gets his own rebound throws it
off the glass out of file on the
back in the game as well doncic resting
thompson firing that's another three
29 assists
oh my goodness what a shot
curry
wiggins curry triple
[Applause]